New Hampshire is all about the outdoors
in every season most will tell you it's
why they live here but everywhere you
look you see signs it's not like it used
to be when I started studying climate
change and Martha Carlson is a sugar
maker one of the hundreds responsible
for creating New Hampshire's iconic
maple syrup about a decade ago she
noticed her trees were changing the
syrup was getting darker so she went
back to school and got her doctorate to
understand what was happening
the short answer climate change it's
less sweet than it was a century ago a
century ago the average sap from a tree
would be three percent or even three and
a half percent now it's 2 or maybe 1.8
percent sugar now why is it less sweet
the tree is making less sugar because
maybe they're too hot climate change is
impacting all aspects of life in New
Hampshire and this state has an outsized
role in determining who gets to be
president and they say climate change
really matters to them but it doesn't
seem to impact their vote after all when
he was on the campaign trail Donald
Trump pretty much denied climate change
and the state overwhelmingly voted for
him in the last primary that is a
challenge for Kathryn Corkery of the
Sierra Club I think trying to find
solutions to the climate crisis is hard
and there is not a lot of solutions that
come to mind quickly that will address
it I can explain politics I can just
tell you about buds and Carlson though
thinks it's changing because the climate
undeniably is the sugar producers that
I've met are by and large conservative
thinkers they've said climate change was
a hoax slowly over these last how long
has I've been 10 years or more they've
seen the darker syrup and they have seen
these odd seasons the seasons are much
more variable seeing the problem and in
a unique position to try and fix it by
deciding the people that make the
policies getting another chance this
Tuesday patty call hain aljazeera
sandwich New Hampshire